i'm very grateful uh to know you from
the day i met you it was some
big shindig at saturday night live and
you were i was meeting i think megan for
the first time and she did she
introduced me to this lunk she was with
in a
black leather biker jacket
and you had one of those big chains that
holds probably one key to a safe deposit
box in switzerland
not a motorcycle key but um and i
immediately
liked you very much and
we got to know each other really well
over the years we've had a few
adventures in misadventures uh
we may have discussed this once but you
and i took a long bike trip that ended
with your chain exploding and i saw you
rebuild the bike using rocks
i tell people that you gathered all the
pieces and said i must now in that offer
minion way i must now reassemble this
chain using the tools available
and then if you proceeded to rebuild the
chain and i thought this is before it's
how long ago this was there was no uber
there was no getting on a cell phone and
saying let's get this let's just leave
our bikes here and throw them in the
weeds you you have had a explosive
career since then you've accomplished
many terrific things
you're uh you know known around the
world uh for your work in television and
in film you're also
a world-class uh worker of wood and
you've written many books i still think
watching you rebuild that bicycle with i
think three rocks and it took about an
hour and a half but you did it was one
of the most impressive things i've seen
anybody do it puts all your other work
to shame
[Laughter]
well uh thank you there there was a lot
of over egging in that pudding that you
just prepared uh
and i i mean
there was just a lot of no there's not i
saw it
the chain blew apart into
not every link separated from every
other link that's true that's the only
egg i added to that only the and only
the master link blew open and uh and i
was luckily able to find the pieces
that had to be knocked back together
see again i'm contrasting what you did
with what i would have done in the same
situation were i alone and my chain had
exploded and there was no way to contact
or ask for help i would have taken my
own life
i would have killed myself
in those woods
in the southern part of
lake washington you wouldn't have been
able to because you'd get a rock and you
wouldn't know how to use it i would try
several times to kill myself with the
rock
um and then a passing motorist would
notice i think that's conan o'brien
smashing away at his own head with a
rock
and they would pull over and take a
photograph they wouldn't try and stop me